welcoming in a man who can get spiked
through it Spike Lee through the 33rd
Street entrance at Madison Square Garden
whenever he pleases from Sports
Illustrated senior writer of NBA and
also the fight game Chris Mannix how are
you Chris
who's that more first-day difficulties
you or Dan at this point you know what
I'm gonna go with Leon Rose president of
the New York Knicks how about that one
Chris there's a new president and now
let's have a total poop show with the
most famous Nick fan ever
how about that one Wow I mean it's wild
because these are the types of battles
the Knicks have you shouldn't be in I
mean if you think about it you know that
whole Spike Lee bruja happened you know
after maybe the best win of the entire
season where the Knicks knocked off the
Rockets and that's what everybody should
be talking about instead it's you know
James Dolan versus Spike Lee and you
mentioned Leon Rhodes I mean part of
this story that's perplexing as well is
the fact that Leon gets named Knicks
president and he kind of press
conference and I actually asked the
league I go is this even like just by
the rules don't they have to do
something when they introduce new
president hmm and some of the league
told me is like look we we whatever rule
we wouldn't we couldn't imagine a team
doing this like acting this way so yeah
this is just one misstep after the other
for the next they're there they found a
loophole in terms of being so
incompetent right that's what you're
basically saying that we can't stop it
because there's no rule to stop it
because we never thought a team would be
so incompetent Lee run is what you're
essentially I mean more more or less
rich I mean that was basically the
message out there unbelievable okay so
then what what nothing happens right I
mean the guy still owns a team and then
and and and the NBA is not doing a
single thing to address this problem
bring him in and basically say let's
let's help you or what can Leon Rose do
tell me about him and how he might come
in and actually fix this thing
well I guess it depends on what kind of
autonomy Leon Rose has and that's not
entirely clear to me yet to my knowledge
he hasn't hired any staff of his own at
this point you would assume that that's
coming but he hasn't done that at this
point and you'd love it if Leon had
complete autonomy or he could say all
right we're going to amend this fence
with Charles Oakley we're going to fix
this problem with Spike Lee
you know I'm an agent I'm good at
relationships we're gonna deal with the
PR problems first and then the real
basketball problems but that's never
been the case in New York I mean Scott
Perry is a former agent you know Phil
Jackson a complete autonomy and these
types of things you know they keep
happening so I look I I don't know I
don't know about Leandro's the guy you
know that makes the most sense as the
team's you know de facto general manager
but this is just certainly not off to a
good start Chris Mannix you're on the
Rich Eisen show let's talk about
relevant basketball teams starting with
the teams here in Los Angeles the Lakers
it seems that there's more of a
groundswell now for LeBron to be MVP of
the Association where do you stand on
that subject right now I think pretty
clear runner up but I don't think
anyone's touching on us this year and
nor should they I mean it's it's a
tremendous story you know that LeBron is
is crafting right now with his and I
want to call it a bounce-back year but
it was the first injury-plagued season
of his career last year and and
certainly that was a factor for him and
a lot of people wanted to get back to
that top level ever again especially
defensively but you just kind of have to
take a step back and look at what Yanis
and the Bucks are doing I mean he's
putting up the the type of numbers that
we haven't seen really since shots no
MVP season I mean he it's like her
almost 30 points the 2013 rebounds I
mean it's just astronomical production
the Bucks you know could wind up with 70
wins
you simply can't take that away from I
don't I don't think you should just be
the MVP rich to be unanimous MVP he's
been that that good not even a single
other vote huh Wow
so because you're voting first place
right and look LeBron
every single second place well he should
be second place on probably every single
ballot but if you're voting against
Yanis those units because you maybe you
have JavaScript Mugen you want to go to
the story it's not because you're voting
for the most valuable player in in 70
not 1920 well I got to tell you I'll ask
you um because it's it's it's rare for
me to look up at the standings on March
4th and see an X next to a team's name I
mean the fact that the Bucs have already
clinched a playoff spot right now
I don't recall the last time we saw
something like that Chris yeah it's
certain look it's a testament of the box
and it's equal testament it's just how
crappy the bottom of Eastern
Conference's mean if you get a clinch a
playoff spot when I think the 8th seed
has 27 wins right now it is six seven
games under 500 at this moment so
they're having a great year but you know
Golden State from a couple years ago
play in the East they probably would
have had the same type of clinching
situation Chris Mannix you're on the
Rich Eisen show okay so what what else
other than MVP and can the Lakers do it
tell me the other intriguing story in
the NBA is we've hit our early March and
were we're a few weeks away short weeks
away from the eighth and final playoff
spot conversation leading into the
playoffs what we through with this I
mean look the biggest story to me is can
anyone challenge Milwaukee in the East
and it's gotten interesting over the
last couple of weeks with the way Boston
is played you know last night
notwithstanding and Toronto's just
continued you know success despite not
having Kawhi Leonard I mean the Raptors
they clearly believe that they can win
this year because if they didn't they
would have traded Marcus all or Serge
Ibaka
I mean both these guys had significant
value they were expiring contract at the
very least the Raptors probably could
have gotten back a draft pick in return
but they kept that duo intact largely
because they want to challenge the orbit
sounds the size of Milwaukee in the in a
conference final situation Boston I'd
been skeptical bosses front line but
we're into March right now and they
still have a top five defense and Daniel
I'm still defending at a high level and
his cancer hasn't been exposed yet at
some point I'm about to admit that I was
wrong and the self-esteem has enough
beef in that front court just Alexes it
certainly have more than enough storage
I mean Payton has become a bona fide
star Kemba Walker when he's healthy if
Kemba Walker Jalen Brown is one of those
borderline all-star players I mean ever
to be able to school with everybody and
their front court is showing that
they're gonna be able to compete with
the bigger front line so what about the
notion that Zion has a shot at Rookie of
the Year based on what gamma read didn't
exist maybe you might say that
Zion could get the you not over RJ
Barrett or you know Coby white or any
these other guys have emerged from this
class but study jobs been awesome from
you know really day one and he's been
the driving force behind a Memphis team
had no business being the plastics this
year you know having a good chance of
winning that number eight seed so I
think you know it's another one where
you got to watch people don't want to
vote for Zion should watch John Moran
play he's been you know durable he's
been excellent I mean he he to me should
be a runaway Rookie of the Year and
which team for the final six weeks has
the most on the line to try and finish
up well for a coach and roster I can
kind of guess which what your answer may
be but I do want to just open end that
question for you Chris Mannix what my
guess be if you don't mind my asking
the Sixers right they're gonna finish up
in the next six weeks and obviously
they're gonna get into the to the dance
but I guess that that would be unless
there's another team out there whose
coach might be contemplating retirement
or might get fired or the team might get
blown up based on how they do finish up
know but the three weeks ago I would
have absolutely agree with you I do
think that the injury to Ben finem and
the injury could well indeed if those
guys wind up missing time in the
postseason it might give Philadelphia
chance to say well we and we repair
messed up this year though we'll make
some tweaks around the fringes and our
guys will be healthy next year we'll
bring everybody back I mean
Brow's situation is most interesting
because i wonder if the fiction
society's not the guy did they make a
run J right because three right is good
right the next guy you know he's the one
everybody is looking at and saying when
are we going to get him to come to the
NBA that all the credentials elite level
college coats I've worked with USA
basketball and people around them you
know really believe that and he's got
that mindset you know they're the NBA
coaching mindset that Drive season pass
and John Beilein doesn't for example so
that's what makes no doubt they're
thinking the most interesting if the
Sixers believe that they can lure Jenny
right you know interest kind of hometown
job that could spell the end for Brett
Brown that's what makes it most internet
Chris Mannix here on the Rich Eisen show
on this radio station and what you're
listening to it and you can watch it on
youtube.com slash Rich Eisen show for
all three hours every single day what
did happen would be line what in the
world did go wrong with John and never
ever should have been put in that
position I don't understand I mean even
if nothing about you know how John
Beilein was going to coach that beam and
you know kind of the attitude he was
going to take you know with veteran
players the idea that a sixty
six-year-old lifetime college coach with
no NBA experience was going to work was
ridiculous it was and this isn't Monday
morning quarterbacking for me I mean I I
thought so when I said snow at the time
and I didn't think it would happen this
quickly but I expected it to end poorly
I mean they're just there are certain
coach that you look at and say they've
got a shot I mentioned today right I
think Tony Bennett that Virginia is not
a potential candidate down the line they
don't always have to be super young like
like some of those guys I mentioned but
I think they've got to have their finger
on the pulse of the NBA in some way
shape or form and and beeline didn't and
if you want to get in the weeds of it
yes I think going through a team that
had veteran players that were used to a
certain way of coaching is that being
kind of hands-off you have practices you
know that went from like twelve to two
instead of like nine to four and lived
long home stretch that John Beilein had
I think that was you know a big time
problem from the
a critic standpoint but he just rich
this wasn't built for free coaching in
the NBA and like some coaches aren't
Rick Pitino wasn't John Calipari wasn't
and John Beilein joins that list no
truth to the rumor that Dan Gilbert got
beeline out of Michigan on behalf of his
alma mater Michigan State there's no
truth to that rumor whatsoever that's a
bit above my pay grade
I'm just trying to say hunt that one
down Chris just on my behalf you know I
Boston College alone welcome John
Beilein to the college ranks at Boston
Common
don't you think he's got to be the the
hottest sought out college basketball
coaching candidate period I mean why not
the guys that means you might have more
insight you might have much better than
I do at this point I mean one thing I
don't know is like how much money did he
wind up getting from the Cavaliers on
that deal I mean he had a deal to tatum
in the neighborhood of five million
dollars every year that was a five-year
deal so you know does he want to give
that money up keep some of that money
how interested is he in coach in the new
versus some thinking respect that the
NBA was kind of like this retirement
gift for for Johnny Lima got a college
basketball thing the going was good and
the getting was good rather before like
this became even bigger success Paul and
maybe isn't one occurrence again but if
he does I think there's any doubt that
there'll be a lot of teams look at the
hiring all right in the few minutes left
with you Chris Mannix let's take your
Sports Illustrated hat off put your
disowned hat on now with just a couple
weeks remove of Tyson Fury's beatdown of
Deontay Wilder the conversation about
everybody involved in the fight game in
that weight class is what well it's
certainly a new new star in the division
and I think one of the things that
excites people is that we could
eventually start getting the super fight
at the heavyweight ranks that we've been
looking for I mean as long as Deontay
Wilder and Anthony Joshua were holding
belts and were at the top of their their
their respective you know political
divides we weren't going to get that
fight it just wasn't going to happen
anytime soon or maybe not at all time
series in a bit of a different situation
Gerry from day one who's mindsets always
been I'm going to fight the best I'm
gonna fight the bed and my promoters
work for me and they're going to go out
and make a deal so if you can win this
rematch on July 18th with Wilder I think
there's no doubt we'll see Wilder over
security versus Joshua and maybe because
the odd taste knocked off a couple of
times down the line in 2021 will get you
know Wilder versus one of those two
preferably Joshua at that point so I
think what happened you know a couple of
weeks ago rich was maybe the best it
could possibly happen to heavyweight
boxing there's kind of a break in the
logjam in the politics of it all and the
potential leaf to have consistent
superplex not division well I mean Tyson
Fury is is definitely magnetic there's
just no two ways about it I mean a video
that we reposted here at Rich Eisen show
on our Twitter feed at Rich Eisen show
the night of the fight of fury just
unburdening himself unfiltered to to me
here in June about his battle with
mental health went spread like wildfire
where people could not get enough about
Tyson Fury and his story it's great that
that the the story like that in a fight
like that brought in no mainstream
outlets like yourself and others to get
to know a guy like me I mean I've
covered him since like 2013 and you know
certainly chronicled his downfall after
the win over Vladimir Klitschko and I
don't know if I can remember too many a
better redemption stories to be you know
400-plus pounds and to lose all that
weight and become an elite athlete once
again and knock off the most fearsome
puncher in the game that's really
impressive for Caixa career I think like
as we look ahead to the rematch of the
third pod against say the Noah thing I
wonder about is what could happen a type
of the next couple of months I mean as
as know by now you know he he's meant to
be in a good place when he gets what
he's kind of fight for what he wants and
he wanted to fight back and get back to
the top of the heavyweight division once
again she did that when he'd be proud of
me Klitschko and he was the undisputed
heavyweight champion a unified
heavyweight champion that's where things
kind of fell apart for him you know he
kind of felt like he got everything that
he wanted and it was all kind of
downhill from there I hope it doesn't
happen but one of my questions about
series now that he's accomplished what
he set out
to accomplish because we still have that
same edge did you still train the same
way and commit to the fight with the
same mindset because so much one
how about Deontay Wilder and where he is
right now but the guy still has an
eraser of a right hand so you come in in
any kind of questionable suit he is
going to knock you out
well I mean I don't know how you could
read anything into it either Chris
because you know looking pre-fight when
when the fighters were on camera fury
was the one singing and dancing and
Wilder was the one locked in focused and
then apparently his 40-pound costume was
the thing that got him all wobbly legged
too quickly and then fury made short
work of him and sang
Don McLean's American Pie with the whole
crowd how do you view like what his
version of locked-in is right like one
thing with fury is that he knows and he
knew out before my first fight that his
antics got under the skin of Yonsei
wilder and it affected him and made him
fight maybe a little bit differently in
that first fight so he's he's all about
kind of the mind game that you can play
I mean as far as wilder zones I mean he
was basically playing blame game bingo
after that fight where it's like it's
the costume award then it was the
referee and you know that it was there's
a handful of other things people aim you
know as a result shot by fury I mean he
just he kind of went out there and
spread the blame with a fire hose off
anyone that would listen to him and I
didn't think I was a particularly good
look for him so but clearly I think will
be the exactly and fighter you know
least in terms of his antics and then in
the next fight Dirk who he is but I want
to see how he trains would be still
committed before I'm all in on Piper
quite Chris thanks for the time brother
really appreciate it and you were the
first guest in the history of this show
being streamed live on YouTube and as
they say in the NFL nobody can take that
away from you Chris
nobody I will that will be up on my
Twitter feed with me you should sir you
should sir and I appreciate that at si
Chris Mannix and also on Instagram thank
you Chris thanks the call brother will
chat all right you guys it's Chris
Mannix right there